glen yunken to his credit is talking
about it he's the governor of virginia
he says he's going to reverse his
state's planned ban on gasoline-powered
cars enacted under the previous
administration governor thanks so much
for joining us tonight this is one of
those topics i think you're one of the
only
governors in the country who's talking
about this why do you think this is
worth addressing
well first of all tucker it's great to
be with you and when virginians elected
me governor last year they wanted to put
a stop
to an effort from the previous
democratic-led administration to turn
virginia into california well little
little did they know that they had
signed legislation and and tied virginia
to decisions are going to be made in
california so not only did they pick the
a state that has demonstrated it has no
idea how to run itself to tie itself to
but they abdicated their responsibility
to serve virginians and so we find
ourselves today with this ludicrous law
that virginia has to follow california's
laws and so we're going to go to work
and stop this because virginians should
be making decision for virginians and
that's why i was elected governor last
year to stop a government that was very
comfortable telling people what to do
all the time
and forgetting that we're here in fact
to make our own decisions freedom in
fact matters in virginia that's why
parents make decisions about whether
kids wear masks today that's why people
can make a decision about whether they
want to get a vaccine or not and i'm
going to go to work to make sure they
can decide what kind of car they want to
buy
well i think that's right and thank you
for doing that i
and that's the premise of democracy is
it's self-government which is curiously
lacking at this point i wonder how many
virginians were even aware that their
cars were about to be banned
well i don't think i don't think any i
think they did it very quietly and in
fact
the law itself is ludicrous virginia
last year two percent of all cars sold
were electric vehicles and to say that
in 2026 we're gonna have 35 we're going
to phase them out totally by 2035 is
just
ridiculous but on top of that and more
so this is about elected officials
completely abdicating their
responsibility to make the laws and the
regulations for virginians based on
virginians elections and so that's why
they voted for us in november that's why
we swept the house races that's why i
have a republican attorney general and a
republican lieutenant governor and we're
going to go to work and make sure we get
this turned around come our legislative
session in january
so i don't know if you can see a return
monitor where you are but i want to put
a video on the screen of charging
stations in california that appear to
have been completely taken over by tent
cities of vagrants living in front of
them there's this weird syndrome i'm
sure you see it among your fellow
governors where the basics fall apart
you can't have air conditioning in
august and there's some guy
smoking meth on your front steps but
we're gonna save the climate what what
is that weird impulse
well i i think it is i think it is a
complete disassociation with what real
people are worried about
what virginians and americans are
worried about is inflation and schools
and a solid education and oh by the way
parents being listened to and safety in
their communities and yet here we had
the virginia legislature under democrat
rule last year forget that they work for
virginians and tie it to california next
thing you know they would want to tie us
to their homeless laws or their tax laws
which is why everybody is leaving
california so this is a chance to
re-establish virginians making decisions
for virginians based on the on the
leaders they elect
that seems like an inherently moderate
and sensible idea to me um and i'm glad
you're doing it governor younkin of
virginia thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight